that seems good
well one I apologize it's really hot in
here and my air conditioner is on so
that noise will be here the whole time -
I'm wearing sneakers with heels in them
I'm sorry I don't know who I've become
three I don't apologize I said we're
doing a cooking videos today I had an
epiphany last night and everyone's like
I'm going out that was supposed to be
some sort of digestive system joke I had
an epiphany in the middle of the night
last night because I knew I wanted to do
a cooking video and I couldn't think of
anything to do and I decided that I'm
gonna make fish and chips
traditionally fish and chips otherwise
the British food it is deep fried fish
and french fries because the Brits call
fries chips because they're charming and
today I decided I'm gonna do the
American version of fish and chips which
is fish fried in a coating of fresh duck
chips the best thing to do when you're
already in a hot kitchen is cook with
fire although I have not looked up
exactly how you make fish and chips so
I'm just gonna guess I got salt and
vinegar chips because people put both
salt and vinegar on traditional fish and
chips keep me along with the theme and
they have Fritos because they're just
delicious so first things first I don't
know I don't know for sure exactly the
fried food but I think that you dredge
judged rich I think that you dredge the
protein source in milk and eggs and then
dry stuff let's mix up some eggs and
milk and put them into bottles for
dredging dredging sounds like some sort
of weird religious sexual activity I
don't know how many eggs to put in here
brand new 3 because that's enough that a
boat could go through without it being a
tie all the time did you know the eggs
were invented by and you're gonna die
you're not begging begging out
ergonomic nest ergonomic this one's not
gonna happen for you now let's mix it al
I should probably flower right I don't
have flowers the only flower I have is
my
[Music]
right now let's go milk into a bowl all
right now let's crush up some chips so
the way I'm going to do this that I
believe might be the cleanest way to do
it is that I'm going to put chips in two
separate bags and then crush the bottom
some vinegar chips were invented by the
less popular hip-hop duo salt and
vinegar oh you smell sour Fritos
just so organic burritos were invented
by an organ donor on the street who is
all like Fritos giving my toes away for
free read each of those someone's like
I'm hungry
please like let's make chips cooking is
fun got it ish now let's put the chips
in some bowls they're party party party
party party party now let's put some
olive oil in the pan for the Friday at
about them you know the amount that is
the correct amount okay their oil is
getting hot so let's charge it I can do
this
I got Cod which I've heard is the poor
man halibut and I thought let's just get
caught for the halibut God was invented
by God who just misspoke when he was
trying to toast someone his name trying
to introduce him spell it himself he was
like I'm Cod and someone was like
shooting who what's your name like have
you tried this cod
god it's a fish I'm God why is this so
long like this
what so I'm gonna we're gonna put it in
fill then I'm gonna put it in eggs and
then we're putting the chips
getting the chips and then we're going
to put it in the hot oil
ah there we go
I'm indoors of them wash your hands I
guess so we take this line okay you're
going normal size oh and should I do
that
into the milk into the egg now into the
Fritos oh they're not all in there now
oh my god they do not look good they do
not look good they look like two snakes
molting I don't want to put that in my
mouth now that I feel more with her than
it was I'm going to attempt to put one
over
oh it's all broken okay oh are you
cooking that's like a major component
here I am sweating so much outside and
splashing ah
it means it's me yes turn it off make it
stop cooking always a leisurely casual
time let's try it I'm gonna go for the
salt and vinegar fish first
he'll be that's very good okay mister
the frito Spanish
okay that one a little more of an
acquired taste but overall not a failure
right Fritos Titus at home but not
unless you I'm know how to avoid food
poisoning
and you take a shower I don't know I'm
so fancy
non-elastic la Tokyo I'm great at
karaoke